we thought this NewsHour with a
developing story armenia's prime
minister says 49 of his country's
soldiers have been killed in violence
with Azerbaijan now the fighting began
along their Shad border early on Tuesday
Armenia says the azerbaijani Army began
shelling military positions around three
cities but Azerbaijan says it was
responding to a buildup of Armenian land
mines and weapons leaders are working to
stabilize the situation let's bring in
elno mamodov he's the deputy foreign
minister of Azerbaijan and joins us now
from Baku thanks very much for taking
the time just first of all give us an
update of the situation along the border
is there a ceasefire that is now holding
or are we still seeing fighting
well Armenia has been selling Azure
Jenny military positions for a few weeks
now
which shelling has been intensified over
the last few days and over the same few
days Armenia started amassing heavy
weaponry and Armament along the deemed
border between Armenia and Azerbaijan
and what happened overnight was the
large-scale provocation by Armenian
military against azerbaijani positions
as well as the shelling of employees and
civility infrastructure as you are well
aware Azerbaijan has been engaging in
large-scale reconstruction efforts in
those liberated areas in Latin and
Calvary Logistics which have been
heavily shelled by Armenia over the last
few days okay because of course Armenia
says that the azeri Army began shelling
and indeed that 49 of its soldiers have
been killed
we are always facing such kind of
statements by Armenia we're not
interested in this Blame Game Azerbaijan
has no interest in any escalation along
the dean border with Armenia not least
because of the large reconstruction and
rebuild exercises
yes we have suffered losses the
casualties among azerbaijani military
personnel and there will be reports
coming soon okay what was the
significance of these areas where this
fighting is happening because it's not
the nagorno-karabakh region is it
this part is not part of Karbach this
part of the of the escalations overnight
they took place over the deemed border
and the reason I'm calling it it's a
Dean border is exactly because of almost
a 30-year occupation of azerbaijani
sovereign territories by Armenia which
did not allow us to
um start the delimitation and
demarcation works with Armenia and all
only following the second karabak world
that we first entered following
occupation Calvary and Legend States and
only in May this year the first time the
commission on build mutation and
dementation uh met on the border on Dean
border between Azerbaijan and Armenia on
May 24th and so far they've been only
two sessions of that Commission in order
to engage in uh the limitation Works uh
that we've been precluded from starting
over the last 30 years in terms of
things if I can just jump in there
because I just want to get an idea of
the situation along that border because
of since the 2020 War uh between
Azerbaijan and Armenia and
nagorno-karabakh there have been Russian
peacekeepers situated along this area
where are they now what is their status
the dean border as as we've been
discussing so far this is not the area
where the Russian peacekeeping troops
are temporarily deployed there are
temporarily deployed in Parabola and the
situation from time to time we also face
escalation and shelling by occupying
Armenian forces which are still there in
paragraph despite their obligation that
Armenia took in accordance with the
November trilateral statement that ended
the second karabakh war to withdraw all
the occupying forces that been there for
30 years from azerbaijani's Sovereign
territories and has been admitted by the
high-ranking officials of Armenia just a
few weeks ago the troops are still there
okay which is a cause of a serious
concern for Azerbaijan which is a clear
violation of that trilateral state okay
France is saying that it's going to take
this this recent conflict to the U.N
security Council it's going to raise it
there is that something that you support
do you support the eu's role in finding
long-term solution a peace treaty with
Armenia
yeah uh European Council president he's
been very active in uh bringing the
leaders of two Nations together the
latest meeting took place in Brussels on
August 31st and it is uh regrettable
that this escalation and provocations by
arminius happening against that Petrol
in a situation where we're hoping to
finally achieve a peace with Armenia
whereas the only thing that we're
witnessing our tactics and delays on the
part of Armenia not to start the peace
process not to nominated
representatives to the Peace Commission
that we propose would be established
although the formally declared that they
are accepting five principles for peace
at Azerbaijan proposed back in March
still there's not much progress on that
front and the provocations are
continuing so this is very regretful
that we're witnessing this okay I'll
know Mama Dove we appreciate you taking
the time to join us there from
Azerbaijan and we should point out of
course that Armenia counters what that
view is and says that Azerbaijan indeed
started this latest drop of violence we
will be getting both sides of this story
throughout the day